[Music]
protesters wearing the uniform of a
commander of Pakistan's Army
and on fire this historic Jenna house
named after the country's founder
Muhammad Ali Jinnah
Imran Khan says these demonstrators
wielding flags and chanting slogans for
him had nothing to do with his tarike in
South party or PTI
this was a planned conspiracy to set the
buildings and core Commander's house on
fire I have video evidence of
gun-wielding provocateurs inciting our
people
thousands of workers and party leaders
have been arrested during violence
following Imran Khan's arrest last week
after being granted bail this former
Minister ran back to court as Security
Forces tried to detain him again
Han holds the head of the country's
powerful military responsible for his
removal from power in April last year
videos and audios have emerged
apparently showing some party leaders
calling on followers to charge towards
the headquarters of the Pakistan Army or
GHQ everyone mother daughter child let's
go to GHQ I've spoken to other leaders
and God willing we will go to the GHQ
this is Pakistan's Army chief who's been
named by Imran Khan as being behind a
campaign against him General convened a
special meeting of military leaders his
message was quote restraint will no
longer be exercised we're meeting at a
very difficult time soldiers and
politicians have condemned the violence
and recommended Trials of accused be
held under the Army act rights activists
are concerned about the escalating
tensions and possible trials under
military courts they say when one
politician is agitating against the
military and others at odds with the
Judiciary Pakistan's leaders need to
pause and defuse questions
but Imran Khan has again urged his
followers to be ready for further
protests
there may be 70 to 80 000 people but on
the other side it's 230 million people
when people of Pakistan decide they will
not allow them to violate the
constitution tolerate attack on the
Supreme Court and we want elections no
longer life under these corrupt people
when we decide that we will get our real
freedom
Human Rights Watch has condemned what it
called the use of excessive force by
Pakistan's government and the arrest of
hundreds of political workers It also
says supporters of Khan used rocks
Molotov cocktails and assault rifles do
attack police and set fire to ambulances
police vehicles schools and destroyed
property it said in a statement the
Pakistani government should uphold the
right to Peaceful protests while
responding to violence with the minimum
force needed
Imran Khan journalists commentators and
analysts have also been arrested
journalist matthiola John was abducted
during Imran Khan's period in government
he says what the current government is
doing is also unlawful in spite of our
differences as journalists I think it's
very unfair that he has been picked up
and he has suddenly disappeared state
must act very fast for his safe recovery
but for now tensions are escalating as
no political or state actor appears
ready to change their positions
Islamabad